[Música]
en el mundo
nacen 15 millones de bebés prematuros al
año
esto es casi el tamaño de la población
de guatemala
esto quiere decir que desde que comencé
a hablar han nacido por lo menos cinco
éxitos prematuros
estos pequeños son el mejor ejemplo de
luchar por la vida y por los sueños
desde muy temprana edad
eran las 4 de la tarde cuando yo recibí
la llamada estéfani mi esposa debíamos
dirigirnos al hospital ella había roto
fuente
estando en el hospital supimos que era
inevitable nuestro tercer hijo thiago
debía nacer inmediatamente
tenía apenas 24 semanas de gestación eso
es menos de 6 meses
según la sociedad española de
neonatología un bebé esta naturaleza
tiene apenas un 37% de probabilidades de
supervivencia
y aún más sus probabilidades de futuras
discapacidades o complicaciones de salud
son casi absolutas
pero aún así nosotros nunca perdimos la
esperanza de un milagro
apenas dos semanas antes estábamos con
stefan y los niños en la playa de
monterrico
era medianoche y veíamos los fuegos
artificiales de año nuevo y en ese
momento dios reconecte con un libro que
había leído ese año racing the lights o
persiguiendo la luz del día de chino que
vio en su obra o que ni nos comenta que
lo más espectacular de los fuegos
artificiales no son las luces sino es el
sonido de las bombas un descubrimiento
que él hizo cuando comenzó a perder la
vista a causa de un tumor cerebral
pero kelly en su obra también nos nos
habla de algo que se llama los momentos
perfectos que son aquellos pequeños
lapsos de tiempo en los cuales estamos
viviendo algo tan placentero una
felicidad tan auténtica que los sentimos
en lo más profundo
y en ese momento estando en la playa con
mi esposa mis hijos viendo los fuegos
artificiales yo supe que estaba viviendo
el momento perfecto y reconocerlo me
hizo sentir una enorme gratitud
entonces fue así cómo se implantó en mi
cabeza mi resolución de año nuevo todos
los días por un año no comentaría en la
aplicación de notas de mi teléfono una
muy breve razón para agradecer algún
evento del día cualquier evento pequeño
o grande simplemente agradecer por algo
haría eso de una forma muy sencilla al
final de mi jornada y fue así como
inicié mi diario de la gratitud
pues es normal que cuando cuando piensas
en agradecer por algo lo primero que se
te viene a la mente son las cosas
positivas y favorables porque no
necesitan no necesitan mayor análisis y
en mi caso así lo fue mi primer
agradecimiento fue dar gracias por ver a
mi hijo de 5 años enterrado en la arena
con una risa tan genuina estás ahí ves a
tu hijo pasando pasándosela también que
tú te sientes también
pero sientes gratitud por lo que estás
viviendo por la inocencia de tu hijo por
su salud
fue así como documente mi primer
agradecimiento ya sólo me quedaban 364
más no se preocupen porque no los voy a
mencionar todos
pasaron tres días llegó el día de mi
cumpleaños y ese día de gracias por
tener un pastel iluminado de velas
estás ahí soplar las velas de tu pastel
pero sientes gratitud por estar
cumpliendo un año más de vida
sientes gratitud por tener ahí a tu
familia cerca completa y sana o
simplemente ya se te olvidó y has dado
todo esto por garantizado
pasaron los días y yo comenzaba a
explorar un poco con las razones por las
cuales agradecer un día por ejemplo de
una película de acción extrema y
simplemente me hizo sentir tan bien y yo
dije esto es lo que voy a documentarlo
en mi idea en mi diario y de hecho así
lo fue
pasaron unos días más y todo marchaba
bien hasta que llegó el día del
agradecimiento número 13 el 13 de enero
ese fue aquel día que recibí la llamada
y que fuimos al hospital
estando en el hospital tuve la
oportunidad de acompañar a mi esposa en
la sala de operaciones
yo acariciaba su pelo toma su mano y
dejaba sus mejillas mientras nacía
nuestro bebé en un estado extremadamente
prematuro mi esposa estaba llorando
sabía el peligro que sea destinada para
nuestro nuestro hijo
thiago nuestro bebé nació pesando una
libra y tres onzas
a pesar de su estado tan prematuro en un
bebecito plenamente formado sus manitas
sus piecitos e incluso en su rostro
podríamos ver una semejanza a sus dos
hermanos
sin embargo al día siguiente un pulmón
de thiago colapsó y tuvo que ser
sometido a una cirugía que lo dejó
terriblemente débil ya los pocos
momentos fuimos llamados a tomar una
dura decisión
y desconectar las máquinas que sostenían
la vida de nuestro pequeño luchador las
máquinas respiratorias
o prolongar su sufrimiento ante la
posibilidad de un milagro
stephanie todavía se encontraba bajo el
efecto algunos medicamentos y no se
sentía bien por algunos momentos yo
sentía que estaba tomando la decisión yo
solo
y un hacía la pregunta cuál es la
decisión correcta
pero correcta para quien para evitar el
sufrimiento del bebé o para nuestra
comodidad ante posibles implicaciones
correcta ante las probabilidades médicas
o correcta ante nuestra fe religiosa
simplemente no había una salida fácil
pero nosotros finalmente aceptamos la
decisión de tener a un hijo ángel en
nuestra familia
tuvimos
la oportunidad de estar con un con
thiago
estuvimos con él hasta el último latido
de su diminuto pero gran corazón
imagínate tener a tu bebé resignación
tus brazos
sentir su calor y darte cuenta que será
la primera y única vez que podrás
hacerlo
es tremendamente difícil y lo es aún más
cuando tú tomaste la decisión de
desconectarlo
esa noche estaba tendido en un sofá cama
del hospital y saqué mi teléfono
y abrir la bitácora de agradecimientos y
empecé a revisar lo que había
documentado en los días anteriores todo
por cosas principalmente positivas
pero esta vez será distinto porque
obtenemos sentimientos de culpa tenía
una gran tristeza y además tenía una
frustración tenía cólera y yo pensaba
cuál es el sentido de dar gracias el día
que tu hijo recién nacido no sobrevivió
no pude escribir nada
apague mi teléfono y con una sensación
áspera voltee la cabeza sobre el
almohada
sin embargo a los tres o cuatro minutos
me puse a pensar tal vez y hay algo por
lo que hoy puedo agradecer
es cierto estamos devastados
pero habíamos tenido una oportunidad de
amor
y por ello damos gracias
y eso fue lo que documente en mi diario
haber tenido la oportunidad de cargar
pesar y sentir el calor de thiago previo
a su partida
ese día aprendí que siempre hay algo por
lo cual uno puede agradecer en el día
siempre
por esos días me topé con una frase de
charles window que dice la vida es un
10% lo que te sucede y un 90% cómo
reaccionas ante ello
una frase poderosísima de actitud
mi proyecto lleva apenas un 5% de avance
es decir me quedan 347 agradecimientos
por documentar pero ahora ya no se
abordaría con una actitud totalmente
distinta ya no solo daría gracias por
los momentos positivos eventos positivos
sino también por aquellos negativos o no
necesariamente favorables por ejemplo un
día de gracias por haber amanecido
enfermo porque ese día me recordé lo
bien que se siente amanecer todos los
días sintiéndome pleno
otro día y gracias por haber estado
metido dos horas en tráfico
porque ese día iba a poner con stephanie
mi esposa y tuvimos mucha oportunidad
una gran oportunidad de platicar otro
día y gracias por haber tenido un día
tremendamente frustrante e intenso en la
oficina porque me recordé que ese tipo
de días son los que me retan y que me
hacen crecer como persona y como
profesional yo creo firmemente que los
días duros y malos son parte de nuestra
felicidad simplemente se trata de
abordarlos con una actitud positiva para
aprender crecer y madurar
es cierto agradecer por cosas favorables
te hace sentir muy bien pero aprender a
traducir lo negativo en algo positivo es
el ejemplo de la gratitud en su máxima
expresión
pasaron pasaron las semanas y un medio
año y un día en la noche de día la casa
y stephanie me recibió con una gran
sorpresa estábamos embarazados de
nuestro cuarto hijo
estamos felices de hecho eso fue lo que
documenten mi agradecimiento número 158
es cierto sellamos con un gran vacío en
el corazón y el derecho al día de hoy
todavía no tenemos
pero nosotros tomamos una decisión y
lograríamos la vuelta a la página para
olvidar a ti sino en vez haríamos de su
misión un legado de gratitud y de
felicidad y eso es mi compromiso
pasaron los meses por lo tanto los días
los agradecimientos y los aprendizajes
pero un día que fue muy particular fue
este día que nos disfrazamos de superman
y de mujer maravilla con stephanie y los
niños
vos te comes así es súper mujer
maravilla
y sabes nos la pasamos también sentíamos
una felicidad tan natural y tan genuina
que estábamos viviendo uno de esos
momentos perfectos como los que imagino
aquellos define en su tipo
y nos tomamos una foto y luego nos
acercamos al teléfono para verla de cómo
había salido yo le dije esto es lo que
voy a documentar hoy en la noche y
precisamente así sucedió pero ese día
aprendí algo muy especial muy particular
y es que cuando tú estás viviendo un
momento perfecto si estás lo
suficientemente consciente
para reconocerlo agradecerlo y
escribirlo se genera un efecto
multiplicador en tu felicidad del
momento es decir tu felicidad extiende
su vigencia
un gran aprendizaje
pasaron los días
y todo parecía marchar muy bien
hasta que llegó el día del
agradecimiento número 326 este día este
afán y fue ingresado
por estar experimentando en las líneas
contracciones
sin embargo a los 4 días éstas
incrementaron su intensidad y al poco
tiempo supimos que he mentado
nuestro cuarto hijo fabián debía nacer
inmediatamente
lleva apenas dos precios de su camino de
nueve meses desde que tenía 27 semanas
de gestación 27 son seis meses
nosotros no podíamos imaginarnos un
mundo con el nacimiento perdida de dos
bebés en un mismo año
fue así como comenzamos amigos de allá
estando exactamente en la misma sala de
operaciones en el hospital donde
estuvimos días meses antes me acariciaba
el pelo de mi esposa tomaba su mano de
esas cirugías estaba llorando sabía
nuevamente el pedido que se aproximaba
para nuestro bebé
estaba naciendo nuevamente en un estado
extremadamente prematuro
sin embargo a pesar de la de la angustia
y de la incertidumbre es algo diferente
y es que estamos cargados de positivismo
estamos seguros
javier nació pesando tres días sus
primeros días perdió peso y ua pesar dos
libras y cuatro bolsas
pasar nuevos días las semanas y los
meses en retiro donde nuestra mayor
fortaleza pero ante todo paciencia
porque deberíamos esperar para saber si
nuestro bebé podría tener un desarrollo
normal cualquier bebé esa naturaleza
corre el riesgo de complicaciones de
salud o riesgos de futuras
discapacidades
desde el nacimiento de fabián yo me
había preparado emocionalmente para esos
momentos pero sentí un escalofrío
[Música]
cuando conecté dos puntos entre dos
eventos de ese y no me hables
y eso fue lo que documentó
el catálogo de cristiano nos preparó
para esto
fabián es un luchador y saldrá de lanús
además ese día fue muy especial porque
el día de acción de gracias un día
emblemático para nuestro directo de
gratitud y además recibimos un gran
regalo
por primera vez me permitieron besar a
mi hijo a mi canción
un luchador que tuvo un coach a su
hermana
hoy javier es un bebé sano
de un año de otro mes es un evento a
este mundo lleno de gratitud lleno de
felicidad
se puede ver eso en su expresión
es cuando uno se topa con los momentos
desafiantes en la gratitud ahora su
verdadero valor y desata su potencial de
aprendizaje y que aprendió en este
inolvidable año
la gratitud es algo que todos llevamos
adentro en nuestro adn simplemente a
veces está ahí dormido esperando a que
le despertemos pero cuando esto sucede
nos coloca unos lentes de optimismo y
así todo lo que nos pasa lo reciclamos
con positivismo para que nosotros
tomemos el control de nuestra felicidad
la gratitud despierta nuestra conciencia
para para sentir mejor todas nuestras
vulnerabilidades estamos sintiendo en
nuestra conciencia de lo que pasa a
nuestro alrededor a mí particularmente
me enseñó dos cosas la gratitud uno a
reconocer mejor los momentos perfectos
todos vivimos una serie de momentos
perfectos a lo largo de nuestro día
simplemente a veces vamos demasiado
rápido que no hacemos una pausa para
reconocernos y perdemos una oportunidad
de cosechar estos frutos
también habré aprendido a reconocer
mejor las intensidades de la vida y esto
es a unir los puntos entre los distintos
momentos en estos tres pesos en los
positivos pero particularmente los
negativos o los desafiantes porque es
hasta que túnez esos puntos y buscas un
sentido en ellos que realmente entiendes
que todo pasa por algo
todo
y un claro de agradecimientos
puede ser tu forma de convertir la
gratitud en un hábito porque escribiendo
tus agradecimientos todos los días
empiezas a generar empieza a entrar a
este modo de piloto automático que sin
darte cuenta comienzas a ser más
agradecido más agradecido por todo lo
que tienes y todo lo que te rodea
no nunca te rodea
un agradecimiento que para mí fue
particularmente difícil y fue el último
haber tenido la oportunidad de dar
gracias 365 veces mientras yo estaba
documentando ese diario y terminando lo
documentar recordé exactamente un año
antes yo estaba en la playa con mi
familia viendo los fuegos artificiales
de año nuevo
y aunque decía en el tiempo de stephanie
y un futuro ángel implantada en mi
cabeza la habilidad de llevar un diario
del gatito
fue así como el año posiblemente más
triste e intenso de mi vida se volvieron
más caras más gratificantes
a pesar de haber quebrado como nunca
hoy hasta prueba
emprende tu diario de agradecimientos
crea tu propio estilo
descubre la sincronicidad es de la vida
descubre los momentos perfectos y bellos
siente los que amplifiquen la plenitud
de tu vida que te ayuden a descubrir la
felicidad
dicen que la gente feliz está que es más
agradecida
pero la verdad es que la gente
agradecida es la que tiende a ser más
feliz y quién es feliz hace más feliz a
quienes la rodean
así que llevando un diario de gratitud
todos podemos contagiar felicidad al
mundo muchas gracias
[Música]